the eh-2-zed of isms xenophobe ISM
xenophobia is a term usually describes
the fear and hatred of the foreign
others it is a fear that the other the
less deserving foreigner will take away
your way of life xenophobia has a long
history the Romans and Greeks labeled
those outside their borders as
barbarians uncivilized brutes who needed
to be conquered for fears of them
contaminating the Empire and xenophobia
reshaping the political debate to date
in the campaign for Britain to leave the
EU we were startling warned about the
threat of the hordes of foreigners
supposedly swarming to the border of
fortress Britain the Prime Minister at
the time of the vote David Cameron or
shittin bricks it in part by badly
misjudging the power of xenophobia when
he assumed that people would not vote
themselves poorer because they don't
like poles living next door across the
Atlantic Donald Trump was elected on a
wave of xenophobia against the imagined
criminal gangs drug dealers and human
trafficking supposedly pouring across
the border with Mexico build the wall is
the perfect slogan of our xenophobic
time but it would be wrong to confuse
any phobia with racism though the two
are often related racism is more than
the fear of the other it is a system of
oppression based on the belief that
so-called races are superior to others
just as much of the brexit vote was
based on a desire to curb white
migration into Britain we have seen
xenophobia in places like South Africa
where migrants from other African
countries have been violently attacked
by other black people who are themselves
poor and lacking in opportunity it is a
logic of scarce resources of the country
being too full to sustain the outsider
and a reminder that you can be the
victim of racism and perpetrate
xenophobia the windrow scandal was
caused by the hostile environment a
xenophobic policy aimed at squeezing out
illegal immigrants by making checks of
documents routine in all areas of life
including work education and even
visiting the doctor the unsurprising
result was that many including those who
had legally come from the Caribbean
post-war lost their jobs who were
deported to countries they had long left
behind but it was also the logical
conclusion
of decades of immigration policy that
purposely restricted immigration from
Britain's former colonies in the
Caribbean Asia in Africa the expansion
of freedom of movement from Europe was a
continuation of welcoming white
migration whilst closing the door on
people of color xenophobic fears are
easy to stir when inequality increases
the pain is so-called natives feel
through poverty and inequality are
turned unto the foreigner trying to jump
the queue it is no coincidence that
following the increased inequality since
the 2008 financial crisis xenophobia has
been on the rise across the world
thankfully there is a way to tackle this
trend when society is more equal and
provides for all there is no need to
fear the other thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon